that gets really really interesting when
you start talking about how bitcoin
works and why it's so similar to
the primary value delivered function of
militaries
it's because all civilization all living
creatures
obey the social consensus protocol
that those who project the most kinetic
power
in the most
clever way
earn the right to set the state and
chain of custody of limited resources no
one gets the option to like unsubscribe
from this social consensus protocol
right
those who project the most kinetic power
set the state and chain of custody
okay
that is true
not only for animals right you like if i
threw a juicy steak in between a pack of
wolves who gets the steak whoever gets
there first whoever's the strongest
right so animals actually establish
their own pecking order based off of
their capability to project power
right humans are no different we're
animals too there's limited resources we
we it is an existential necessity for us
to establish a pecking order to achieve
consensus on the legitimate state and
chain of custody of all property
we do it through kinetic power
projection the cool thing about kinetic
power projection is it's a
permissionless protocol
i don't need
the permission
of another country or another person if
i can project enough power in the clever
way right that's how you establish a
permissionless control structure over
all
as you would say analog property
but what was really really fascinating
about bitcoin specifically
is that it takes this exact same power
projection game
right but instead of kinetically derived
jewels it's electrically derived jewels
and that
is really
really interesting it
it works effectively the same exact way
as militaries do what's the role of the
military the role of the military is to
project so much kinetic power that it's
too expensive not to cooperate with
whoever owns that military
right that's the that's the main deal
the role of the military is to
countervail the control authority of
someone that has been oppressive right
so the reason why the united states
exists is because
people in north america
started feeling that the you know
monarchy was being oppressive to them so
they exercised their permissionless
control structure over property and here
we are now we identify as
americans so like
that's important to point out it's not
just because you see this all the time
on twitter people are bashing that like
usd
you know is proof of war literally
everything is proof of war anthony
like if you identify as a citizen in a
country
that is because people
projected a bunch of kinetic power to to
create that rule of law like the state
of ownership of everything is as a
result of either kinetic proof of work
or
contractual legal proof which only
exists because someone won a war to
to legitimize that
okay so how is bitcoin different bitcoin
bitcoin takes the exact same game
right that that all
animals have been playing
for
four billion years
but it transposes that game digitally so
instead of kinetic proof of work
you do
electric proof of work
those who project the most electric
power
and win the competition
earn the right
to set the state and chain of custody of
the underlying piece of property in this
case satoshi's
and if those entities which we would
call miners
ever become oppressive right if they
ever just start mining empty blocks and
not allowing people to
transact over the ledger
then the beautiful thing
about bitcoin is that it restores
the ability for all users to countervail
the control authority of those
oppressors through what projection of
power and in bitcoin denominated terms
it always gets easier to project more
power it's never been cheaper to mine
right it's cheaper to mine now with an
s19 than it is to mine with you know
your usb miners from a while ago in
bitcoin denominated terms which means
it's always getting easier and easier
for users to countervail the control
authority of oppressors if they emerge
and so
that's interesting because then
what effectively is the primary value
delivered function of bitcoin is not to
create a piece of digital property that
part to me is boring
the part that is interesting to me is
you have restored a permissionless
control structure
over any a property
using the exact same way like the exact
same
mechanism as warfare
and you've done so after civilization
has is effectively stalemated itself
with nuclear power the problem with
nuclear weapons is it's too expensive
to
use them right so we have lost
civilization has lost their ability
uh to have permissionless control
structure over property right if
does that make sense like it makes
complete sense
yeah it we risk nuclear annihilation
correct to to use this
um to use this power projection protocol
now so that that's bad by the way it's
not the first time it happens happens
all the time in nature
so
nature animals will actually grow
random power projection mechanisms out
of their foreheads so that they can
continue to play the game and establish
pecking order and to achieve consensus
on the legitimate state and chain of
custody of resources like
territory right we call them antlers
right we call them you know look at bugs
with their weird horns on the top right
they evolved a way to continue the power
projection it gained but do so
in a in a way that won't
threaten the species right like we're
not gonna kill each other
anymore we're just gonna awkwardly clash
our antlers together and then that's how
we're gonna decide who gets to own what
and so
this sounds ridiculous i know
but i keep telling people bitcoin are
human antlers
we have re-established a way
to achieve a permissionless control
structure over property which is needed
to defend against
oppression
and
but still maintain
fairness right still maintain the
ability to achieve consensus on the
legitimate state and chain of custody of
a property and so that's pretty cool we
should probably monetize that
right right
and like people are like well you know
there's no way bitcoin would ever
um
you know end war it's like no i'm not
saying it would end war right like
obviously kinetic power projection would
still be
necessary
for all forms of physical property that
people value right like there's low
probability that i'm going to stop
valuing water that i'm going to stop
valuing
you know land
that i'm going to stop valuing contracts
that i'm going to stop valuing oxygen
but no one says we have to monetize
those things what if
the cool thing about
money is it can take any shape it wants
it's a shape-shifting thing
and so if you transpose money
into a digital commodity
and re-establish a power projection
permissionless control structure over it
then what you've effectively done
and i know this is wacko
but what you have effectively done
is digitally transformed warfare itself
from a kinetic power projection game
into an electric power projection game
and so in so far as we fight each other
to defend against money
we don't need to and the last thing i'll
say before
opening it for comments is this
and this is why i drew that
picture because we have the picture we
have the picture here that uh that we're
gonna show everyone
okay so
the thing i wrote this in class i was
not paying attention to class
um the thing that bothers me about like
these esg accusations against bitcoin is
like they fundamentally misunderstand
what the point
of bitcoin is right they fundamentally
misunderstand what the point of all that
energy or all that power projection is
the point of projecting that much power
is to make it too expensive
to attack
the the ledger right like to make it too
expensive to be uncooperative with the
people who who use bitcoin
this is exactly what the military does
right every single
the power of every single
bomb the power of every single bullet
the power of every single engine behind
every single plane or ship or sub or
truck or tank the power of every
heartbeat of every service member of
every military in the world
is measured in watts
and those watts are spent
explicitly
to protect and defend resources
up until bitcoin to protect and defend
monetary resources
and to say that bitcoin is a waste of
energy
is effectively the same as saying
your military is a waste of energy it's
a waste of energy to have a standing
military to protect our
rule of law or whatever we're trying to
protect
like yeah it's inefficient to sail a
bunch of carrier battle groups through
the ocean right you know it's more
inefficient anthony than sailing a bunch
of carrier battle groups or testing
about a bunch of nuclear missiles all
the time
being invaded
being conquered that's pretty
inefficient and if you want to learn
what happens to people who decide not to
build a standing military read history
history is literally just
you know
a story of all the countries that
decided that it was too inefficient
to have a standing military right
and so it's like oh it you know
bitcoin's bad because it projects too
much power it's like saying
you know dollar for dollar i wish my
military projected less power so you
don't understand the point
of bitcoin the point of bitcoin is to
defend the network to defend every user
that volunteers
to make that underlying piece of
property their form of money